(car engines rumbling)
(car horns honking)
(Russian folk music)
(speaking foreign language)
- And over in the US, we
hear a lot about Russia.
Like, a lot.
- I would consider the principal threats
to start with Russia.
- Prosecutors indict another
batch of Russian nationals
in an alleged cyber scheme
to interfere in the 2016
presidential election.
- Russia.
- And in the midst of
all these firestorms,
I'm here while Russia is
hosting the 2018 FIFA World Cup.
Which, for now, is giving
their people a chance
to be seen in a different light.
So while my Russian buddy,
Eric, can't join me,
I've luckily met Kristina here
to help me out as I explore
the Russian capital.
How do you say cow in Russian?
- [Kristina] (speaks in foreign language)
- (speaks foreign language)
What does that say?
- [Kristina] McDonald's.
Cool.
- [Kristina] You can now break the law.
- This is an international
terrorist incident.
- [Kristina] (speaks foreign language)
- (speaks foreign language)
We're here in a square.
Alright, so we're at this Georgian place.
What's the name of the restaurant?
- (speaks foreign language)
- (laughs) You won't manage.
- What are things, I guess you think,
I should know or be aware of about Russia?
- Russia's a big country, really very big,
and it has a lot of people
and people are really very different.
Some people are open minded.
They want to be friends
with all over the world,
and some people hate everyone.
I think it's because their life is hard,
because life in Russia
sometimes is very, very hard.
We have a lot of poor people.
We have lots of problems
inside the country,
but we have to make our
life better ourselves.
No one will help us.
Not the government, not the President,
only we can make our life better.
- To learn more about daily life here,
I decided to chat with some locals.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Hello.
- You know, we should trade music,
so you know, what's a good Russian artist?
- (speaks in foreign language)
- (speaks foreign language)
- [Kristina] Do you like it already?
- I'm digging it, Kristina.
(Kristina laughs)
♪ (singing in foreign language) ♪
Do you guys watch or listen
to Western music, media, TV?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Kristina] The Big Bang Theory.
- Big Bang Theory? (laughs)
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Rihanna, Beyonce.
- I'm not a big Beyonce fan.
- (speaks foreign language)
- Are you not? How come?
- Wow, that's a face even Americans make
when I tell people that.
(women laughing)
No, I'm more of a Michael Bublé guy.
Do you guys like Michael Bublé?
- Who is it?
- Michael Bublé?
- Maybe they know him more
as like Mee-chi-el Bub-lay?
(Kristina laughs)
How do you say voice
of an angel in Russian?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- (speaks foreign language)
♪ And I promise you kids that I
give so much more than I get ♪
♪ I just haven't met you yet ♪
How do you feel the day has gone so far?
- Very hot in Moscow today,
but I like the time that
we're spending together.
- When we've been filming,
you look at me like I'm a crazy person.
- (laughs) You're funny.
- There's a lot of
stereotypes about Russia.
I mean, are there any stereotypes
or myths you can debunk for us?
- In our country and in our
cities, we don't live in bears.
- (speaks in foreign language)
- We don't have bears as pets.
- (speaks foreign language)
- [Kristina] No bears in the streets!
- Everyone keeps talking about the bears.
- Look around, look around, where's?
Bears!
(roaring) Where are you?
Where the bears?
- (speaks foreign language)
- There may be a stereotype
that we are gloomy
and not friendly but we're nice
and we like foreigners.
- We are open to different cultures.
- [Aria] But how do Russians actually feel
about the United States?
A country with whom they have
such a complicated history.
- I'm in love with the U.S.
I've been an exchange
student for one year in Utah.
- Oh, you lived in Utah?
- Yes, exactly. For one
year. I was 16 back then
and I used to live in the Mormon family,
and it was the best time of my life.
- When I think about America,
I remember about American Hollywood,
American sport, but no negative.
No negative.
- It depends on the generation.
Perhaps for the older generation,
they kind of, strictly,
they don't like the politics.
- I think it's politics.
- Yes.
- To be honest.
- It's all part of politics.
- I know some people, maybe one or two
who say something worse about U.S.
but it's not my friends
this is another people,
and this is people who never been in U.S.
- And if an American is watching
this, what would you hope
that they learn or take away about Russia?
- That Russian people are very open-minded
and they're kind.
- That you are people and we are people.
- (speaks in foreign language)
- The best in world it's peace.
And you want peace and we want peace.
- Guys from U.S., guys from Russia,
we are friends forever and
ever and ever and ever.
Russia and U.S. forever.
- That was really moving, man.
- Thank you.
(happy music)
- [Aria] Russia is
country embroiled in a lot
of controversy, and a day
in Moscow is hardly enough
to capture everything
about an entire nation.
And while this video can
only provide a small slice
of life here, I'm glad
today gave me a chance
to meet some great people who, ultimately,
proved to be no different than you or me
or most others on this silly planet.
So for now, I'll just leave you
with some wise words from a Russian cat.
(Russian folk music)
- [Cat] (speaks foreign language)
(happy Russian folk music)
- [Aria] Do you hug in Russia?
(woman laughs)
- Yes.
- Hey! Unsolved is on a new
channel and now your part.
- Subscribe here.
- That was my part.